(logo whooshing)
- [Narrator] This program
is a presentation of UCTV
for educational and
noncommercial use only.
(calm music)
- Good afternoon.
Forgive my voice, a little
something is in my throat.
But in any event, I am William Lester,
professor of chemistry
and chair of the Hitchcock
Professorship Committee.
We're pleased, along with
the graduate council,
to present Dr. Leon
Lederman, this year's speaker
in the Charles M. and Martha
Hitchcock Lecture Series.
As a condition of this
request, we're obligated
and happy to tell you how the
endowment came to UC Berkeley.
It's a story that
exemplifies the many ways
this campus is linked to
the history of California
and the Bay Area.
Dr. Charles Hitchcock, a
physician for the army,
came to San Francisco during the gold rush
where he opened a
thriving private practice.
In 1885, Charles
established a professorship
here at Berkeley as an expression
of his long held interest in education.
His daughter, Lily Hitchcock
Coit, still treasured
in San Francisco for
her colorful personality
as well as her generosity,
greatly expanded her
father's original gift
to establish a professorship
at UC Berkeley,
making it possible for us to
present a series of lectures.
The Hitchcock Fund has become one
of the most cherished endowments
of the University of California,
recognizing the highest distinction
of scholarly thought and achievement.
Thank you, Lily, Charles,
and now a few words
about Dr. Lederman.
Leon Lederman is internationally renowned
for his research on neutrinos,
ghost-like particles
that pass through
everything in the universe,
and on subatomic
particles known as quarks.
He was awarded the National
Medal of Science in 1965
and the Wolf Prize in physics in 1982
for discovering the bottom quark,
which establishes the existence
of a third generation of quarks.
In 1988, Lederman was
co-winner of the Nobel Prize
in Physics with Melvin
Schwartz and Jack Steinberger
for his discovery of the muon neutrino,
proving that there are at least
two families of neutrinos.
His research has provided major advances
in the understanding of weak interactions,
one of the fundamental nuclear forces.
In addition to his work as a researcher,
Lederman is also a leading
proponent of science
and math education at the
high school and college level.
He founded the Illinois Mathematics
and Science Academy, IMSA, in 1986,
and has served as resident
scholar since 1998.
IMSA is an internationally recognized
educational institution
for developing talent
and stimulating excellence in teaching
and learning and mathematics,
science and technology.
Lederman is also an outspoken advocate
for the Physics First movement,
which seeks to rearrange
the current high school science curriculum
so that physics precedes
chemistry and biology.
Dr. Lederman received his master's in 1948
and his PhD in 1951 from
Columbia University.
In 1963, he proposed the
idea that eventually became
the Fermi National Accelerator Laboratory,
where he served as
director from 1979 to 1989,
and is now director emeritus.
He previously served
as the Eugene Higgins
Professor at Columbia
and as the Frank L. Sulzberger
Professor of Physics
at the University of Chicago
before becoming the Pritzker
Professor of Physics
at the Illinois Institute
of Technology in 1992.
Lederman is a founding member
of the High Energy Physics Advisory Panel
of the United States Department of Energy
and is a member of the
National Academy of Sciences.
He's also a past president of AAAS,
the American Association for
the Advancement of Science.
It is during my service on the AAAS board
that I first met Leon
and encountered his magnetic personality.
Please join me in welcoming
Dr. Leon Lederman.
(audience applauding)
- Thank you very much, that
was a really good introduction.
Could you do it again?
(audience laughing)
Okay.
Well, it's great to be at Berkeley,
I haven't been here for some years.
Great to see many, many old friends.
I'm delighted to be here and only sorry
that I haven't prepared the
most spectacular presentation
in world history.
But I thought I would talk today
about something I've been
working at for some time,
and that is on science education.
I started getting involved, well,
I started getting involved in education
as a professor at Columbia where teaching
was considered a very serious
obligation of the faculty,
something I enjoy doing.
And something curious
happened, I went to Fermilab
as an administrator and found myself
ill at ease because I
wasn't teaching anymore,
I'd do funny things
like catch some post-doc
in the corridor and pin
him against the wall
and teach him something.
Eventually, the group of post-docs called
for a meeting with me
and tried to figure out what was wrong.
And eventually, they got
it, that I'm not teaching,
and that's a bad thing to do suddenly.
And so that started a series
of Fermilab educational activities,
Saturday morning physics for
hundreds of high school kids
that came on Saturday to
listen and things like that
and ultimately, the Illinois
Math and Science Academy,
which I'm very proud of,
it's just won a major award
by the Intel Foundation as
one of the best high schools
in the United States in the
teaching of math and science.
That's good stuff.
So I thought I would regale you today
with some of my efforts in education
and we'll try to use
all this modern stuff.
What I asked for was do you have,
at Berkeley, a slide projector?
And I got a blank.
Usually, when I ask
that, they say oh yeah,
we have one, it's in the
closet on the third floor,
so I suggested that here,
but there was no third floor,
no closet, so.
But we have a good effort
and I hope that you'll be able
to see some of these things.
I have to recognize from this introduction
that fame is an important
ingredient in being a physicist
especially with awards and medals.
This was illustrated this by
being on a crowded train coming
out of Chicago one day and
it stopped at this institute
for mentally handicapped
patients that the train stopped
and the nurse got on the
train with a clipboard
and a bunch of patients
and she organized them.
And as very crowded she counted
them, one, two, three, four,
and she looked at me and say who are you
and I said I'm Leon Lederman,
I have a Nobel Prize in Physics
and I'm director of Fermilab.
She said, yeah, five, six.
(audience laughing)
So here's this thing.
I hope we'll get it going.
A Scientist Looks at Science Education
and I'm very well aware
that education is a complex phenomenon
and we all work at it.
When most of us who've been in
academia we work at it hard.
I think a lot of us, especially
in the teaching of physics,
are aware of difficulties and so on.
And so a lot of this that I'm
gonna tell you is experience.
My point of view is that
of an experimental particle physicists
to gradually and then
hopelessly became immersed
in the educational process
and I've been now at it full
time for well over 10 years
with mixed results.
First of all I worry a lot.
I worry about the the whole gamut
of educational things from pre-k
which is now very important
especially around here
where Scientists in the
Crib has become a textbook
for many of us and it
came out of Berkeley,
to all the way to grade way
up in the college graduates
and worry about the teachers,
the poor kids left out
of some of the advantages,
the gifted kids are we
taking care of them?
The college science dropouts,
the ninth grade biology
which is my pet peeve.
Science illiterate college graduates
where for too many colleges
it's still I forgot the
one semester of rocks for jocks
or whatever it is that's
considered to be a proper course.
I worry about global
warming, the Dow Jones,
all kinds of things.
But most of them not terribly relevant.
This is something you
may not be able to read
but I just want to say we live in a time
of escalating global crises.
Problems so complex,
interdependent, far-reaching
and resistant to traditional
modes of thinking
and problem-solving they
seem to render us impotent.
A short list is the economy.
All of you here especially
in California, know about it.
Joblessness, that goes with it,
the health care system still struggling
and in the Congress.
The problems of global climate
change, the wars we have.
There's enough here to
keep many, many busy.
Yes and then there is the competition,
there's the growth and power
of China and India and Brazil.
But there is also an emerging realization
that scientific, economic, socio-political
and environmental futures
are inextricably linked,
causing us to re-evaluate
policies, I hope,
and redesign strategies.
So what do we do about STEM education.
STEM, of course you all
know, is science, technology,
engineering and mathematics.
It's interesting that
the engineers have gotten
into this nickname twice and
maybe that they deserve it.
Science, technology,
education and mathematic,
where we now train our students
to think in decidedly different ways.
We have to since clearly the old ways
of teaching have failed.
Einstein said something like,
the thinking that created our
seemingly intractable problems
will not be able to solve them.
And so when we're talking about education
and we have a recognition that
goes back certainly to 1983
but probably long before that
what we must do to have our students open
to creatively generate new knowledge,
new questions, new ideas
and globally collaborate
to wisely improve the human condition,
to have them think in
decidingly different ways,
clearly we must teach in
decidingly different ways.
So there is an enormous burden we have
on our educational system
which is very difficult to implement
as anybody who's worked in
education will assure you.
So 21st century is a different century.
It's a knowledge and
information based society
which will produce new
opportunities, new challenges
in all dimensions of our life
and there are three certainties.
Change is inevitable.
Complete coverage of some
subject is impossible
and obsolescence is unavoidable.
I've been told that three years is
about the lasting period
for electrical engineering.
It's not that you have
to go back to school
but the things you've
learned in your four years
at electrical engineering
become obsolete very quickly
and so continuous study is essential.
New technologies, new
discovery, new media,
new social structures,
new possibilities for quality of life,
make lifelong learning
not only a handsy slogan but essential
so that humans can think, create, learn
and collaborate forever.
The divided lifetime,
once upon a time you
learned for 20 years or so
and then for the rest of your
life you apply that knowledge.
That clearly does not work anymore.
Lifelong learning becomes
not a slogan but a necessity.
So how are we doing?
Well as a widely-held
well-documented realization
that the nation is slipping dangerously
in its ability to maintain a
robust, innovative, industrial
and technological society.
Leadership qualities of
science, technology, engineering
and mathematics, which
have made us prosperous,
are rapidly being overtaken.
Cries of alarm are now
being sounded by leaders
in business, economics,
even the Congress and the White House.
And we've never been I think
more fortunately poised
to make progress in a dramatic
way with this White House.
The huge gap and
essential scientific grasp
between the US public and the
21st century requirements,
is a major obstacle to
the reforms we need.
A vigorous technological
nation must have cultural
and social values to sustain the qualities
that underlie progress,
that venerate education,
that respect rationality.
A National Commission, which
is something we often seek,
to make dramatic changes in our system
but can only begin a process
which must be long-term.
Yet our Commissions proliferate
and I've had some experience with these.
So why do our schools fail?
Well there's a lot of reasons
and many of you know these reasons
and these are well known reasons.
Teacher training, teacher morale,
lack of continuous
professional development
on the part of teachers,
inadequate teacher evaluation.
In Chicago the number of teachers rated
as unsatisfactory is something like 0.2%
which is clearly nonsense.
Teachers are not rewarded
for being good teachers
or for teaching more demanding subjects
and conversely difficulty
in handling poor teachers
is a major problem we have.
Outdated, largely irrelevant curriculum
and I want to talk some more about that.
Dysfunctional school management system.
If you think about the nation and schools,
there's 50 states, there are 16,000,
I think, school districts,
then you have the various
committed organizations,
the unions, the PTA, the book publishers,
many other organizations
who seek sustenance, profit
and so on from the school system.
Poverty, lack of preschool preparation,
low parental education,
motivations and so on.
Not nearly enough parental choice
for example charter schools,
suburbs, where do you live,
social promotions, problems,
retention in grade, summer schools,
inability to use beautiful
educational technology
that exists but often is just not used.
The Third International
Math and Science Study
has been widely advertised
and probably many of you
are somewhat familiar
with how we do.
Our fourth graders
actually and not so bad.
They are among the leading component
of our educational system.
By eighth grade our students
do slightly above average
but by 12th grade there
are only two countries
that we're better than
Cyprus and South Africa.
The picture that emerges from these data
as expressed by Bill Schmidt
from Michigan State
University is a curriculum
that lacks focus, coherence and rigor.
National Association for
Educational Progress assessments
are in agreement.
Only 20% of US seniors meet the definition
of proficiency in science.
In 1983 a committee of 10
convened as a National Commission
to design a curriculum for science.
Established the sequence
biology, chemistry, physics,
as clearly alphabetically correct,
(audience laughing)
for high schools but in the year 2008
this is still the sequence being
used in some huge fraction,
well over 90% of our high schools
in spite of profound revolutions
in our knowledge of physics
and chemistry and biology.
How do you get that to change?
Our high school curricula
are over 100 years old
and they were established
in 1890 something
and at least 70 years out of date.
So we need obviously a
sensible science sequence
and I'm going to talk a
little bit about a sequence
which a major change in
which one studies science
in the following sequence.
In which in ninth grade instead of biology
as it is today you study physics
and in 10th grade you study chemistry
and in 11th grade you study biology
and that sequence has
a lot of other effects
that you have to do when
you change the sequence
in the way of coordinating and correlating
and doing something.
There have been a lot of studies,
enormous number of studies.
Here's the Glen Commission report,
Report to the Nation from
the National Commission
of Mathematics and Science Teaching.
I've got a lot of these.
We have, it's an amazing
amount of literature.
There's No Time to Waste.
You can tell from that,
you don't have to read these reports,
you just read the
titles, No Time to Waste,
Vital Role of College University Leaders
in Improving Science and Math Education.
There's the huge interest
on the part of industry,
you know about Bill Gates
with the huge sums of money
that the Gates Foundation
is putting into schools
and you have similar activities
from the major industries.
Intel, Motorola, IBM,
the Business Roundtable
is a very effective group.
More recently Norman Augustine led a study
which produced a very
important report entitled
Rising Above the Gathering Storm
and somewhere some of that
material is percolating
around in the Congress.
I also strongly recommend
for those of you interested
to read President Obama's talk
to the National Academy of Sciences.
Where, just to quote, "I am
here today to set this goal.
"We will devote more than 3% of our GDP
"to research and development
"and improve education
in math and science.
"Represents the largest
commitment to science innovation
"in American history.
"In response to Sputnik,
"President Eisenhower signed legislation
"if you'll remember to create NASA
"and to invest in technology,
science and math education
"from grade school To graduate school."
President Obama said,
"Today I am announcing
a renewed commitment
"to education in math and science.
"American students will
move from the middle
"to the top of the pack
in science and math
"over the next decade."
And so with that, scientists,
engineers, educators,
like superman and superwoman
remove their lab coats,
drop this slide rule,
oh, you don't know what a slide rule is.
It's a piece of wood.
(audience laughing)
Yeah, drop their slide rules,
close their education tomes
and they get involved.
The battle is for the hearts and minds
of the citizens of the nation.
Enlist the population
this complex set of issues
that connects scientific
thinking capabilities.
It's a war on ignorance.
We do seem to like wars
so we decided that maybe
if we have a war on
ignorance that will take away
from the other guys who want
wars on almost everything else.
The battle grounds are the
schools, museums, the cinema,
the TV, the newspapers.
What is being tested is a
commitment to rationality.
So here's the war.
War on ignorance and I must say
that an important component is where
all the business leaders the
Gates' and the Greg Barretts
and Lou Gerstners and
Google and YouTube and so on
governors, congressmen,
engineers, even lawyers.
Is that a misprint?
No, why not?
And then after a lot of
these, lots of reports,
well in 2007 my partner, Shirley Malcolm,
who was the head of education at the AAAS,
the American Association
Advancement of Science
and I co-chair the National
Commission mandated
to fix 21st century STEM education.
So we read reports, lots of reports,
the reports were amazing.
They went back to a report in
1983 called The Nation at Risk
which was beautiful.
Filled with military metaphors
like we've created unilateral
educational disarmament.
Really, I wish I'd thought of that.
Eloquent reports, lots of the reports
and we discovered a
secret room in Washington.
It's called the National
Commission Storage Vault.
All the reports are there.
(audience laughing)
Lots of them.
And we read these reports and
the reports were all sensible.
They told us what we have to do.
They talked about teachers,
they talked about schools,
they talked about curriculum,
they essentially said everything.
The problem was that nothing
was ever implemented.
The failure was a failure to implement
and that's when
in our particular experience
when we tried to implement we found
that the implementation
problem was difficult.
So let me go to my own feeling
for how the subject works.
Out in the research field this
kind of pyramid makes sense
that the base of the
pyramid is mathematics
and if you like computer
science and it's the base
because mathematicians are
very happy to be mathematicians
and not talk to anybody else.
Although if somebody talked to them,
they're not unhappy about it.
Physics and astronomy sit
on mathematics and computer science
because physics and astronomy
require mathematics.
Chemistry, these are
the research fields now,
not education necessarily.
That chemistry sits on
physics and astronomy
because physics provides the basis
for what goes on in chemistry.
There isn't anything, any
chemical phenomenon that I know of
or any chemical process that if you say,
why does that happen you're not forced
to go to physics for an explanation.
And then sitting on chemistry
is modern molecular biology.
And then that's simplification.
There are a lot of hyphenated
subjects and so on.
But this is the hierarchy
that exists in the sciences.
That mathematics plays a
crucial role for physics
and mathematics and
physics support chemistry
and mathematics, physics and
chemistry support biology
and so you would argue that in education
there ought to be some parallel.
The existence of a hierarchy
in the relationship of the sciences is,
I think a profound cognitive statement.
Physics is a foundational science.
It plays a unique role
and that therefore the
sequence clearly ought to be,
physics and then chemistry
and then biology,
rather than the current trend
in over 90% of high schools
still biology, chemistry, physics.
When you reorder the course
you do a lot of other things.
You change the way you teach the course
because when you're teaching
physics in ninth grade
these are ninth graders.
You're lucky if they're taking
algebra one concurrently.
Someday algebra one will
be a 7th grade course
but it isn't there yet
and so this physics has to be conceptual
without problem solving
or major problem solving
but it could be a very solid
important base for chemistry
and a base to explain what a science is
because very, very little in the way
of the process of science
goes on in the schools
and that's an important issue.
Most of the children
that are learning science
in the high schools will not be scientists
but they will be voters
and they'll be citizens
and they'll be important
that they have a grasp
of how science works.
A year of physics gives
students a good sense
of how science works especially
when we tell stories.
Chemistry broadens the
study of matter and energy,
drawing explanations from physics
at the same time deepening
the students grasp
of concepts, more stories.
Biology provides a more
cognitive challenge,
building on the chemistry and physics
that undergirds biological order.
Modern biology is DNA.
What's DNA?
DNA is a molecule.
What's a molecule?
That's made of atoms.
So if you talk about DNA
in ninth grade you've got
to wait for physics to
find out what an atom is.
That just doesn't make any sense.
And teaching biology without
mentioning DNA is another thing
that seems too curious.
So Physics First is what it's called.
That was my biggest mistake
in launching this program,
was not calling it Biology on Top.
(audience laughing)
It was dumb to call it Physics First
because people are very suspicious
especially of physicists.
Probably justifiably so.
so we propose that the disciplinary study
of science begins with physics.
This is A , for 9th grade age 14 or 15
even though the students may
have only just begun the study
of algebra.
Conceptual physics, this
was actually invented
by, I forgot his name,
but a long time ago
as a way of teaching physics to children
who just were impossible mathematically.
But it's changed a lot now.
It emphasizes a conceptual grasp,
does not emphasize much mathematics,
minimum of mathematics
but that doesn't mean you
can't teach a good course
in physics that way.
The belief of some people
that you cannot teach physics
without calculus is just
absolutely incorrect.
The intimate dance of physics
and mathematics can be learned
even with the simplest of equations.
I mean after all, if you say a
car is going 50 miles an hour
where will it be in three hours
and you write down X equals VT,
you've done something fantastic.
You've written down a prediction.
Wouldn't Wall Street like
to have such an equation?
The first year of physics not
only introduces the concept
of the science with its broad
foundations and implications
but it also prepares students
for the study of chemistry
which follows physics.
Let me just comment, if you can see this,
that Physics First is not a new idea.
When we started looking into this,
we found probably 50 or so high schools
that have been doing Physics
first for five, 10, 15 years
and so that it isn't a brand new idea
and most of the schools that
have adopted Physics First,
a long time ago are very happy with it.
They find lots of advantages to it.
The schools that have
been talked into changing
which I know more about,
give us a very positive
reinforcement to the idea
because when it's done with
the enthusiasm of teachers
and the support of the
administration and so on,
you find that first of all students
who take conceptual physics
do better in chemistry.
They do better in biology,
they begin to be interested
in elective courses.
Many schools have
reported growth by factors
of three to five in the enrollment
in elective science courses.
They found women taking
advanced placement physics
which I always thought was
illegal but it's not illegal,
it's in fact a good thing that happens.
So that there is a lot
of positive happenings
in in the subject.
I found my grandson's biology
book which had 9th grade,
9th grade biology and there was a sentence
and at the transmission
of sodium and potassium positive ions
through cell membranes is crucial
to the functioning of nerve impulses.
This is a ninth grade biology book.
This one sentence as the essential physics
and chemistry concepts apply
to a vital element of biology.
In ninth grade biology,
students have to memorize
a meaningless description
of nerve impulses.
That's the problem with
ninth grade biology.
So much of it is memorization.
So Physics First
is the thing I'm trying to sell today.
If you look at textbooks,
high school biology textbooks,
they actually review
physics and chemistry topics
in the first chapters or two
before looking at real biology.
Chemistry textbooks review physics topics,
atomic structure, relevant
forces, definitions
before looking at chemical reactions.
Physics seems to have no
other science prerequisites.
The natural conclusion is to
begin a disciplinary study
of science with physics suitably modified
to fit the development status
of ninth grade students.
It's not simply a switch of
physics and biology courses.
Ninth grade physics is
most commonly conceptual.
It stresses a grasp of concepts
as opposed to problem solving.
I know that many of my own
graduate students can solve
all the problems in the textbooks
but when it comes to conceptual
grasp they're a lot weaker.
As more and more schools
advance algebra studies,
more and more math can be included
in the conceptual physics part.
Biology for students with a year
of chemistry and physics
is a very different subject
and Roger Bighby who has run
an institute in Colorado,
largely for biology teachers
has given many workshops
in which the biology teachers were told,
okay now your students
have had a year of physics
and a year of chemistry
what do you do in biology.
And it's clearly a more richer
and more exciting way
of teaching the science.
So we got a lot of news.
New York Times featured
this several times.
A push to reorder science
which the puts physics first.
The various communities,
the school communities are
all discussing this.
This is now well known.
And little by little we're getting schools
to adopt physics in ninth grade.
I think at last count
there were some 2,000,
a little over 2000 public high schools
that reordered the sequence
to physics, chemistry, biology.
2000 sounds like a large number
but since there are 25,000 high schools,
we have a ways to go.
It's a very slow process.
One of the things you, one of
the implications of this is
not only do you make a
change in the sequence
but you physics, chemistry,
biology and math teachers ought
to give the given time.
I think this is a crucial
issue in changing our schools.
One of the major things teachers
complain about is a lack
of time.
If you ask the math teacher,
how often do you talk
to the physics teacher?
They say well we pass
each other in the hall
on our way to classes and
that's not the way to do it.
So we're pushing very hard for
at least a four or five hours per week
epoch of collegial
professional development
where teachers talk to one another,
design a strategy
for how new subjects are
brought in and so on.
And then why not bring in
occasionally the history teachers
and art teachers and literature teachers
and maybe this is a way to
close the two cultures gap.
Here I recommend E.O.
Wilson's book, Consilience,
which is a very ambitious idea
of the unity of knowledge
which he espouses.
The goal for all students is
science as a way of thinking
designed to generate comfort
with new ideas, behaviors,
situations, characteristic of our times.
You can have numerous
pedagogical excursions
to real-world problems that make inner
and transdisciplinary approaches,
new educational technology.
Here Bob Tinker has been a partner of mine
in some of these developments.
Make visualizations easy
and the approach to abstraction possible
in much earlier grades.
Wide adaption of the inverse
order must have waves
that go way down to k eight
and up to higher grades too.
So what we're really talking about
when we talk about Physics First is really
this revolution we need.
And there's more.
Even more important than that is
the thing I quickly alluded to
that when you design a 21st
century high school curriculum
you have to ask what do we want them,
all of them to remember in 10 years.
They will have forgotten
equations F equals MA
or E equals MC squared.
In the high school
science for all students
each discipline must sacrifice
some time in the content
of the course to the process of science.
How does science work?
How messy is the process of discovery?
The need for open-mindedness, skepticism,
some sense of history, science
as a humanistic activity,
storytelling, what is a scientist?
What are they like?
Social and economic results.
Science is the only universal culture,
it's the same anywhere.
Science is a way of thinking and knowing.
So these are the things one hopes
one can eventually
produce.
And let me try to get to
some quick conclusions here.
A virtue of the P-C-B sequence
is that the physics learned
in year one is used in
chemistry in year two.
Whereas the biology in ninth
grade is ignored from then on,
unless there's a very,
very unusual situation.
Both physics and chemistry
are used in biology,
thus deepening the conceptual
grasp of how science works.
Teachers of each of these
core disciplines should have
some knowledge of the others.
So I think I'm making a case
and there's a huge amount of data.
Unfortunately it's very
hard to get high schools
to track students when
they leave the high school.
But we have huge amounts of anecdotal data
about the benefits of
changing to physics first
and I have some of these things here.
I'm just gonna skip over them
and being delighted to review with you
some of the facts that they work.
As I pointed out,
the process of changing
is a very slow process
we've been working on
this for say 10 years.
We've got 2,000 schools
but we have many, many school districts
and the number of times that
our group of people go out
and talk to teacher meetings
and so on is pretty impressive.
So there is, this process is known.
It's working slowly.
How we get to accelerate
it is a good, good problem.
I do have finally just two slide
that may have some
interest to some of you.
The problem of atoms.
Atom is a very abstract concept
and many parents are worried
that if you introduce
atoms in ninth grade,
the atom is a difficult concept.
For example how many
atoms are there in the dot
at the end of the sentence.
Well it's a million, trillion atoms.
How do you grasp that?
So I tell a story about Aristotle.
Aristotle had a common urge
and so he peed into the Aegean Sea
and in 2,000 years the
water got all mixed up
and so the nice calculation is
how much of Aristotle is
in this glass of water?
And anybody who does the
calculation will find there are
about a thousand atoms.
(audience laughing)
Actually we published this some years ago
and the President of
United States at that time,
(audience laughing)
found an error and this
was in the newspapers.
He pointed out that we made a mistake
of a zero or two.
So anyway I think that's
a good place to stop.
Thank you very much for your attention.
(audience applauding)
- [William] All right questions
and comments please come forward.
Dr. Lederman has agreed
to respond to them.
- [Man] Well I'd like to point out
that there's the STEM technologies
which includes engineering
so if we're gonna make a
hierarchy above biology,
we really should have
something, oh, human ecology
which goes out into engineering
and which has a lot of
sub work for technicians
'cause that's really the
only way that the US is going
to be competitive in the world
of several billion manual workers is
to have everything very highly automated
and so that most of the
jobs here have some aspect
of being a technician working
with a material production here.
So this would apply to me
a rather divert structure
where we don't have the
standard lecture format
and quite the same goals
but really goals of working
with teams to define how
to make useful things
and get them to succeed in the real world.
- No comment I think
that's a good statement.
I know that engineers
have been working hard,
especially I know about
the work done in Boston
where I think they're leading the pack
and trying to introduce
the deuce engineering
at earlier grades.
The only problem you always have is
what do you put in place,
If you're gonna add something
we've got to subtract something.
But I think that is a valid comment.
- [Woman] Hi so you've convinced me
that we should have
physics first what advice
or suggestions or things would
you say that we should do
as future academics or present
academics faculty teachers?
What should we do?
- I didn't hear everything
but you're asking about advice
to others who would foolishly go off
and try to change the curriculum.
- {Woman] I mean if we agree
with what you're saying,
what's the next step?
What would advice or suggestions
do you have for us to do
to help education.
- Well you know--
- For high school,
like you're describing?
- I think the the
problem always is getting
the public involved on your side.
I mean in a way it's not so
hard to find the academics
and the thoughtful teachers to say,
yes this makes sense oh
and administrators too.
But until I think we
can get the, you know,
my fantasy on this is very simply stated.
If I can only get Oprah Winfrey to listen
so she hasn't answered my telephone calls
but someday she will
and what you need I think is
a popular force that says,
look we're not doing well in education.
We've got to do better.
And this is one way to do it.
Now we have a very strong Washington group
that is poised I think
to make important changes
but so I'm speaking on
my pre-Obama momentum
but we're hopeful that maybe
with more ability to spend
time on this particular issue,
we'll get a lot more help from Washington.
- [Man] See along those
lines I was wondering
what you saw in terms of
Arne Duncan's leadership
for the public schools
of the city of Chicago?
Do you see things emanating
from that leadership in terms
of our national directions?
- Yes there are some conversations.
This present Secretary of
Education is a good guy
and I think he's,
in principle we've had
conversations supportive.
When President Obama was my senator
we had some fantastic conversations too
at least in which I was taught awed
by his belief
in the power of science and education.
And he's written papers on the subject.
It's not something you have
to tell him, he knows it.
The big problem now we
have is is the complexities
of our present.
That's why I started out with
the economy and environment.
So many problems are
piling up in Washington
and yet every one of these
problems has a science
and education aspect to it.
So we shouldn't be too fearful
to push education and science
as hard as we can because
that's the right key
in all of these issues.
You know, how do we fix global warming?
Well you know that it's science
and all of these other things are science.
So I think we have to be emboldened
to say this is the right venue
for helping in the present,
under present circumstances.
Gotta work at it.
- [Man] Hi so you mentioned
engineering in Boston
and I actually was working
at the Museum of Science
on the high school approach to engineering
for ninth graders.
So we were sort of your
competitor in some ways
to Physics First trying to do
sort of an engineering first
and as we started down the
curriculum development road,
we were sort of trying to
mesh with you guys and say,
well let's try and get kids
to understand atoms and molecules.
That's a good goal.
But as we got into it and we
started doing more research,
we sort of came to a more
of a macroscopic
thermodynamics approach right,
so flow models which are
bigger in engineering
than a traditional atomic
molecular interpretation,
the kinetic molecular theory.
And one of the things that we found
that is not well addressed by physics
whether in ninth grade
or you know later is
and it sounds esoteric is entropy
or the general running down of things.
And we talked about heat but
heat as a form of energy.
So I guess I have two questions.
One as you move physics to be first
and have this idea of let's teach it
so that kids can take chemistry
and focus on the atom.
Have you sort of not focused
on reformulating things enough
to have a better understanding
of thermodynamics
as a foundation for the other subjects
and I don't remember the second question.
(audience laughing)
- I agree.
I don't have any comment on that.
I think you have a, I'd have
to look in great detail,
you're making very positive suggestions
and I'm sure that somewhere in this,
I mean there's a email
clutch of 30 or 40 teachers
that communicate regularly with ideas
like how to fix it better and so on.
Your statement is a good one.
If you write it up in a little
more detail I'll circulate it
among this crowd and maybe
something good will come out
of the, you know, and specifically out
of the re-formulation of curriculum.
What you make it sounds plausible to me.
- [Man] In this new
reformulations you talk a lot
about commissions and I hear now
that the Governors Association is planning
to get together and rewrite
basically science standards
and it's a question
as to how much they're gonna involve AAAS
and their benchmarks et cetera, et cetera.
But ideas change very
slowly and difficultly,
if that's a word, in this field
and so how do you see that happening?
How do you see new ideas
and really fundamental
reformulations happening
and are you optimistic about that?
- Yeah, well, of course
you're always optimistic
otherwise you don't do anything.
But what you're touching
on is in fact the proposal
that Shirley Malcolm and I tried to sell
in this National Commission idea
that we do need, you know,
during Sputnik we didn't
have the kinds of things
that were needed to combat
the menace of Soviet progress.
So Eisenhower created NASA and so on.
Right now we don't have a
mechanism for implementing
and for smoothing the fact
that we have 50 states
and each you know 50 governors
and the states are beginning
to do things in the way,
which is interesting,
they're I think they're
called P-20 commissions
and they if in fact as the
examples I've seen are correct,
more and more businessmen
get involved in this.
Business men getting involved
in the state manipulations is positive
because they're around
longer than the governors
and we've got to get a mechanism
whereby states can talk to each other.
So that a New Jersey teacher
moving to Missouri doesn't have
to learn a new language.
So that there's a lot we have
to do in the way of the whole system
that I'm you know I waved,
we've got to improve the system
and make it more coherent.
We can't give up local control,
that politically is out
of the question in my view
but we can have a strategy,
a national strategy for standards,
a national strategy for many things
that go into the whole educational mix.
That's what we need to do
and that's part of the
kind of question you asked
that we need an order,
we need to reorganize
this chaotic incoherent system we have.
- [Man] Many students in high school,
including those at Cal right now,
did not take physics last.
They didn't take it second
and they didn't take it first.
They just never took physics.
Is it your hope that if
physics is put first,
more students will take it?
Because that we have a big problem
that people just don't
take science period.
They're not required to take it.
They'll take some.
Maybe they were required
to take one science class
but for the most part in my class
which is the the physics for non-majors
about half the students
have never taken physics.
That's a separate problem from
what order we have them in.
What are your comments on that?
- Well when the city of
San Diego, some time ago,
decided to adopt Physics First
and 9,000 students registered
for physics in ninth grade,
this was five years ago or so,
they went through a huge effort to train,
a big problem is training,
they're not enough physics teachers.
They had to train
physical science teachers
and the biology teachers to pitch in.
But somehow they manage this
and it went on for three
or four years successfully.
They were really getting it now.
The teachers are getting
more enthusiastic about it.
A lot of it has to do
with not forcing teachers
but having teachers being
part of this revolution
in a positive way.
And then in came the parents.
And the parents said, what?
You're teaching physics
to my ninth grader.
It's gonna destroy his mind
or the hormone, you know,
and parents had two
opposite points of view.
One is you're watering down the physics
by giving it in ninth grade,
we should wait for the calculus.
And the other was it's
too much for my children.
Both sets of parents objected
for different reasons
and the the school board
that had been so progressive
in San Diego got fired
and they had to give up the program
even though when you really looked at it,
they were really making
very, very good progress.
Kids were learning,
teachers were enthusiastic.
- [Man] You said 9,000 signed up
but I don't know whether that's
20% or 80% of the students?
- It was all, the whole school,
everybody registered
for ninth grade physics.
- Please join me in
thanking for Dr. Lederman
for a wonderful presentation.
(audience applauding)
(gentle music)